Où que vous soyez dans le monde,
si vous demandez à quelqu'un de vous
brosser le portrait d'un Français,
il vous décrit un personnage coiffé d'un béret,
portant un pull à rayures
tenant dans une main un camembert
et dans l'autre, une baguette.
Alors, pour le béret, le pull à rayures,
le camembert, je ne sais pas.
Mais pour la baguette, c'est sûr,
elle fait partie de notre culture.
D'où vient-elle ? Qui l'a inventée ?
Pourquoi remporte-t-elle autant de succès ?
Je vous raconte cette histoire croustillante,
à la baguette !
En fait, son origine n'est pas très claire.
Plusieurs rumeurs courent à son sujet.
Il y a des trous dans l'histoire
comme dans la mie du pain !
Selon certains, c'est un boulanger autrichien,
Auguste Zang
qui aurait introduit la baguette en France
aux alentours de 1835.
Sa boulangerie, située au 92 rue Richelieu à Paris,
proposait des pains allongés,
comme ceux que l'on trouvait à l'époque,
en Autriche.
Selon d'autres sources, ce sont les boulangers
de Napoléon Bonaparte
qui, au tout début du XIXe siècle, auraient
confectionné les premières baguettes.
Elles auraient été, dit-on, plus faciles à glisser
dans le havresac des grognards.
Enfin, une autre légende urbaine
raconte que la baguette
aurait été inventée sur le chantier
du métro parisien dans les années 1900.
À cette époque, les règlements de comptes
à l'arme blanche
entre ouvriers étaient très fréquents.
Les maîtres d'œuvre auraient alors demandé
aux boulangers de concevoir un pain
pouvant se rompre sans couteau,
comme la baguette.
Bon, comme je n'ai aucune envie
de vous rouler dans la farine,
autant vous le dire tout de suite,
aucune de ces hypothèses n'a été vérifiée.
Ce que l'on sait,
c'est que les boulangers fabriquent
des pains de forme allongée
depuis le XVIIème siècle.
C'est un pain de luxe car ces pains longs se conservent
moins longtemps que les pains ronds.
On sait aussi qui, à partir du milieu
du XIXème siècle,
dans la capitale, des porteuses de pains livrent
ce que l'on appelle des "flûtes" à des clients aisés.
Et ça, c'est pas du pipeau !
D'après l'historien Steven Kaplan, je cite :
« Les gens aisés en ville avaient besoin
d'un pain frais plusieurs fois par jour.
Le grand pain, qui faisait entre 1,2 et 2 kg
était simplement trop gros.
Et ils aimaient davantage la croûte que la mie ».
C'est à cette époque que la baguette
commence à faire parler d'elle à l'étranger.
Des visiteurs comme le journaliste
américain David Ross Locke
évoquent dans leurs récits de voyage
ces drôles de pains longs et savoureux.
La baguette sort de Paris
après la Seconde guerre mondiale en 1957.
Elle remplace même le gros pain pesé
dans le panier standard utilisé par l’Insee
pour mesurer l’évolution des prix et du pouvoir d’achat
preuve que la baguette occupe
désormais une place incontournable
dans l’alimentation quotidienne des Français.
Mais pour comprendre son succès,
allons faire un tour en cuisine
pour voir ce qu’elle a dans le ventre
cette fameuse baguette !
T'as bonne mie toi !
Pour fabriquer une baguette, il faut :
de l’eau, de la farine, un peu de sel
et de la levure ou du levain !
J'adore l'odeur…
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde.
Indispensable pour faire lever la pâte !
Ah bah dis donc,
ça mange pas de pain !
Le secret d’une bonne baguette réside
dans la qualité des matières premières
la farine en particulier et la levure
le respect des différentes étapes du processus de fabrication
et bien sûr le tour de main du boulanger.
Tout commence par le pétrissage,
le boulanger mélange tous les ingrédients
pour obtenir une pâte dont la température finale
doit être comprise entre 23 et 25°C.
Il laisse ensuite la pâte reposer dans le pétrin,
c’est ce que l'on appelle "le pointage".
Un temps nécessaire à la fermentation et
à la formation des arômes du pain.
Quand la pâte a fini de pointer,
elle est divisée en pâtons de même poids.
C’est l’étape de la pesée : 250 g pour une baguette…
Bon, et avec ta boule,
tu pointes ou tu tires ?
Ah non ! Je façonne.
Chaque pâton est travaillé à la main
ou à l’aide d’une machine pour obtenir
la forme allongée de la baguette.
60 cm pour une baguette classique.
Quand le façonnage est terminé, on laisse à nouveau
la pâte reposer dans des bannetons,
des paniers en osier garnis de toile.
Le four est chaud, on va maintenant pouvoir
passer à la cuisson.
Auparavant, le boulanger incise la pâte,
on appelle ça des "grignes".
Puis, il met ses baguettes au four.
La cuisson dure entre 20 et 30 minutes,
au terme desquelles la baguette est placée
dans une pièce bien sèche
et aérée pour qu’elle refroidisse.
Au final, il y a autant de baguettes
différentes que de boulangers.
D’autant que le goût ou la texture de la mie
peuvent être influencés par la météo.
Si Si ! Un taux d’humidité ambiante élevé
aura par exemple tendance à faire ramollir le pain
surtout si la croûte est fine !
Et puis, une boulangerie ne propose généralement
pas une mais plusieurs variétés de baguettes.
Elles peuvent être préparées avec des farines
issues de variétés de blés différents
sans sel, au charbon comme celle-ci,
avec des graines de sésame ou de céréales.
Certaines boulangeries proposent
même des baguettes à 4 croûtons
car c’est le morceau préféré des enfants.
Et pas que des enfants…
j'en sais quelque chose !
Mais la star des baguettes,
c'est elle : la tradition.
Et on ne rigole pas avec la tradition, hein.
Depuis le 13 septembre 1993, la loi est claire,
pour pouvoir s'appeler “tradition”
le pain ne doit contenir aucun additif
et la surgélation est interdite.
Le but : protéger la fabrication artisanale.
Une préoccupation qui montre bien la place essentielle
qu’occupe la baguette dans la gastronomie française.
Elle est tellement symbolique que la France
vient de la déclarer candidate
à l’inscription au patrimoine
immatériel de l’Unesco.
Et ce n'est pas tout !
La baguette a aussi donné naissance
à d’autres spécialités
inscrites au patrimoine culinaire français.
Les tartines du matin
avec du beurre et de la confiture
pour tremper dans le café au lait.
Les mouillettes que l’on trempe
également dans un œuf à la coque.
Et l'indétronable jambon-beurre.
Malgré la concurrence des burgers ou des kebabs,
il s’en vend comme des petits pains
1,2 milliard par an.
Tenez pour l’anecdote, quand j’étais reporter
et que je rentrais d’un pays étranger
je me précipitais au comptoir de mon quartier
et je commandais un jambon beurre
taillé dans une baguette bien fraîche avec du beurre
et une belle tranche de jambon de Paris à l'intérieur.
Ça y est, j’étais de retour à la maison !
Et vous ?
Vous la préférez comment votre baguette ?
N’hésitez pas à partager vos coups de cœur
et toutes vos recettes en commentaires.
À bientôt et bon appétit.